الوضع وطبعا ووهد رؤيه السلطات الايرانيه
لا تختلف ورواياتها لا تختلف مهما اختلف
حجم الاحتجاجات فالشارع النظام يخطط لدعوه
فنانين وباحثين دوليين لمهرجانات افلام
ومسرح لكن في الباحث الخلفيه يعتقل
الفنانين الذين يعارضون قمع المتظاهرين
والامثله كثيره واخرها ترانا علي دوستي
تهم معدومه وان كان النظام قادرا على
اختلاقها نددت الممثله الشهيره باعدام
المتظاهرين نعلم الان عن اعتقال اعترانا
علي دوستي لشهرتها وهي التي شاركت بافلام
عالميه وتضامن معها كبار الفنانين
العالميين لكن خلف الابواب الموصده هناك
اخرون بعضهم مجهول المصير واخرون معرضون
لخطر الاعدام ثمانيه وخمسون شخصا ابي حسب
منظمه هارون الحقوقيه الواقع اذا ليس ولا
هادئه يصرف بكلمات المعاكسه لكلمات
السلطات وفقا وفاق كل التصورات وهكذا ترى
الدول الغربيه قمع النظام المتهمه بنظره
او في روايتها على الدوام بتاجيج الشارع
الايراني علينا القيام بما يجعل المواطنين
يعتقدون ان الاحتجاجات من عمل الاجانب
تسريبات السابقه لخمينائي بدا المسؤولون
في تنفيذها والقي القبض على اسرائيليين
وصفاتهم ايران بالجواسيس كانوا يخططون هنا
لتنفيذ اعمال ارهابيه خلال التظاهرات
خلينا ايه اذا يعتقد وان ابداء ايام مرونه
في ما يتعلق بركائز الايديولوجيا
الايرانيات سيؤدي الى انهيارها ولذلك لا
حل سوى مضاعفه القمع من تنفيذ تهديد قطع
الانترنت الى استخدام التكنولوجيا اختراق
المحادثات الخاصه بالناشطين
وصولا
للاعتداء الجنسي على السجينات ومعرفه
السبب هنا لا يبطل العجب بل يزيد الدهون
ارتدوا الحجاب وبعض عمليات اغتصاب
المتظاهرات يتم تصويرها لاجبارهن على
التزام الصمت مضاعفه القمع وكتم صوت
الشارع استدعى مضاعفه العقوبات الغربيه
واستدعى معه مرور سلبيه كثيره الاقتصاد ان
يتهاوى كل يوم عن سابقه ادنى مستوى
التومان امام الدولار
40,000 وحتى ليله
تحتفل بها الاسر الايرانيه كل سنه وصادفت
هذا العام الحادي والعشرين من ديسمبر
وتقيمها بموائد من الطعام تحولت من سعيده
الى تعيسه فقدت الليله بريقها مراكز
التسوق في ايران شبه فارغه القفزه
الجنونيه في اسعار السلع الاساسيه هي
السبب الايرانيون لا يستطيعون تحمل هذه
الاسعار لان ال 60% منهم باتوا تحت خط
الفقر كل هذه الاوضاع السيئه يمكن ان
تتضاعف مع عدم تخلي الغرب عن العقوبات
الجديده والعقوبات القائمه المتعلقه
بالاتفاق النووي الميت موطن ينعش انتفاضه
الايرانيين ولا نتحدث هنا عن كلمه بيضا بل
تلك التي يصرخ فيها اهالي المحتاجين في
المقابر
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
برشلونه